[Musique]
bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
pour cette édition d' espace autochtone
en direct avec une petite petite minute
de retard mais nous sommes là bien
présent pour je dirais les 45 prochaines
minutes qui vont être bien chargé alors
je sais pas si vous vous en rappelez
mais il y a un an exactement la ministre
d'amour sylvie d'amour ministre aux
affaires autochtones au québec étaient
sur ce plateau nous l'avions invité pour
parler de son travail qu'elle allait
réaliser en tant que nouvelle mini ce
don dans ce poste avec les autochtones
elle nous avait promis de revenir un an
plus tard ce n'est pas le cas elle a
décliné notre invitation
mais on s'est dit c'est quand même
important de faire le bilan de ce que le
gouvernement provincial avait dit qu'il
ferait auprès des autochtones
alors si la ministre n'est pas là nous
avons invité le chef de la pnq l
monsieur ghislain picard monsieur picard
bonjour merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation
nous avons également éviter la chef
adrienne jérôme de lac simon vous la
voyez aller là en duplex à partir de
val-d'or madame jérôme bonjour madame
jérôme goût de vengeance
cui cui et merci mary avoir accepté vous
nous entendez bien de votre côté madame
jérôme will va pas bien bon vous
entendez bien oui ceylan et et puis
comme à l'habitude notre collègue
isabelle picard chroniqueuse à l'espace
autochtone merci isabelle dette
représente encore une fois merci bonjour
alors nous allons donc parler des
réalisations du gouvernement
legault au cours dé quoi 14 15 derniers
mois depuis son élection en octobre
l'année dernière puis évidemment on va
parler de ce à quoi on s'attend pour les
prochaines années aussi mais avant on
pourrait faire en fait une distinction
entre eux le travail du gouvernement
fédéral avec les autochtones et le
travail du gouvernement provincial parce
que des fois on est un peu mêlé alors
tout de suite mettons la table oui mais
en fait il faut remonter à la noix sont
les indiens en 1876 pour comprendre qu
officiellement les indiens et le je
parle en termes légaux parce que vous
savez très bien que j'aime pas utiliser
ce monde là donc les premières nations
vont devenir une compétence exclusive du
gouvernement fédéral
ça va faire une différence ça va faire
deux finalement des citoyens un peu à
part puisque pour l'ensemble des autres
citoyens canadiens ils sont autant de
compétences fédérales que provinciales
bien sûr par contre 7 cette loi-là cette
responsabilité exclusive du gouvernement
fédéral découle elle d'une loi qui est
bien antérieure à celle là en fait une
proclamation qu'on appelle la
proclamation royale de 1763 et là on né
en 1763 on est suite à la conquête
anglaise et la couronne veut affirmer sa
responsabilité de protection à l'égard
des indiens donc des premières nations
qui s'appelait à l'époque des tribus
sauvages
cet aspect où il vient ici l'employé ou
jour absolument oui et cet aspect de
protection toutefois bifurquer avec la
loi sur les indiens donc sa définition
première finalement le change et les
indiens vont devenir dans les faits des
enfants des mineurs sous la tutelle
finalement du gouvernement fédéral
et comme ils sont mineurs et qu'on doit
les protéger on va même aller jusqu'à
décider pour eux ce qui est bien pour
eux donc là c'est important de mettre la
table en ce sens là pour ce faire le
gouvernement fédéral fort comment je
pourrais être affectés à chacune des
communautés un agent des affaires
indiennes qui va être là jusqu'au début
des années 90 à peu près 1 1986 donc ça
fait pas de mal aux dents je me souviens
tout petit il y en avait encore dans ma
communauté
et cet agent l'heure c'est un
fonctionnaire du ministère des affaires
indiennes qui va être en charge de
surveiller les affaires de la communauté
est un peu de les gérer
donc si une décision qui est prise que
ça fait pas la sphère du de l'agent donc
il faut il faut jouer de son influence
pour changer brasser les kiwis
heureusement aujourd'hui les choses ont
changé les premières nations donc les
communautés ont repris en main plusieurs
de leurs propres secteurs donc en
éducation les services de santé les
services sociaux aussi les loisirs
l'habitation le développement économique
tous ceux et gérer l'eau à l'intérieur
du conseil de bande donc les mais par
contre faut quand même dire qu'il y ait
plusieurs priorités qui sont encore
décidée par le gouvernement fédéral
souvent on a des besoins dans les
communautés et le financement n'est pas
nécessairement là ce n'est pas une
priorité du gouvernement fédéral qui va
avoir établi certains programmes pour ce
qu'ils pensent bon pour les premières
menaces dont une fois c'est difficile
d'arrimer les deux absolument donc c'est
encore une réalité
ok maintenant les provinces elle dans
tout ça c'est quoi leur rôle les
provinces ont pendant longtemps refusé
d'offrir aux autochtones des services
équivalents à ceux des autres citoyens
puisqu'il disait que les affaires
autochtones étaient de compétences fait
ça faisait bien leur affaire
ces mêmes provinces par ailleurs n'ont
pas hésité dans l'histoire quand même
affirmer leur autorité sur le territoire
traditionnel autochtone si on passe au
québec à la création des parcs phonique
par exemple ou au développement de la
baie james ou plus récemment au plan
nord les provinces bon on n'a rien à
faire avec vous mais on va quand même
prendre vos territoires puis développer
à l'intérieur de son centre trouve qu'on
se loupe et on a les yeux lui un certain
problème
également il ya la réalité des en
réserve maintenant on sait que un peu
partout au canada comme au québec plus
de la moitié des autochtones vivent en
réserve quand il y en a de plus en plus
bien sûr donc il va voir les services
provinciaux que n'importe quel autre
citoyen va avoir également
et comme autochtone peu importe le notre
lieu de résidence qu'on soit à
l'intérieur d'une communauté ou à
l'extérieur
mais dès qu'on s'en va au cégep ou à
l'université
à part peut-être qui mena bien sûr ou
qu'on doit se faire soigner dans un
hôpital bien sûr on ne les services
offerts à l'ensemble des citoyens
il ya également des différences on
décore haut niveau
au niveau des du niveau de vie des
autochtones dans les communautés et pour
cette raison le les conseils de bande
vont faire appel à la province de plus
en plus dans des domaines comme le
développement économique le logement
l'éducation est le terreau donc il ya
tranquillement eu une relation qui se
bâtit il ya aussi tout ce qui est
l'évolution du droit autochtone
également extrêmement important ce
niveau là puisque que ce soit en matière
de revendications territoriales ou
d'obligation de consulter pour pour les
le gouvernement provincial finalement
qu'un lieu du développement minier où il
ya du développement autres on n'a pas le
choix de consulter et donc on doit
négocier les premières nations les
communautés doivent négocier avec la
province est la province qui qui le fait
pas bien on sait qu est ce que ça peut
donner
on peut aller bon en cours et cetera on
a vu qu est ce que ça a donné avec la
baie james le jugement balouche match
était donc les provinces doivent pas
être à mon avis parties prenantes de ski
sur nouveau docteur alors allons voir
avec le chef picard est ce qu elles sont
partie prenante avec les souhaits des
autochtones avec le travail à effectuer
avec les autochtones
d'abord ce que j'ajouterai oui à
l'information que nous partage isabelle
qui est extrêmement importante parce que
le contexte historique est toujours doit
toujours être au rendez vous lorsqu'il
s'agit d'expliquer un peu la nature de
la relation actuelle avec les
gouvernements
c'est que il ya aussi le contexte
constitutionnel qui a vraiment changé la
donne de façon importante le au tournant
des années 80 qui est vu en quelque
sorte consolide également cette place
nos dix provinces et
ce que j'ajoute aussi c'est que on est
souvent devant un mur ou un cul de sac
sur des questions aussi fondamentales
que la question des territoires et des
ressources souris mais c'est là que tant
le fédéral que la province se compare le
dire facilement dans leur attitude ce
qu'on garde le gouvernement trudeau des
quatre dernières années
c'est vraiment dans ces domaines là où
on accuser le plus le plus grand retard
je dirais en termes de réformes
nécessaires lors sur les politiques qui
sont en cause ici mais en même temps je
dirais que au niveau du gouvernement du
québec parce que c'est ce qui nous
intéresse aujourd'hui donc je trouve ça
extrêmement regrettable que la ministre
ait décliné votre invitation parce que
ça aurait été utile de comparer notre
langue à part et d'autre parce que l'on
a un côté de la médaille on ne va pas
vous côté peut-être démarre seulement
verra mais mais mais mais je pense que
il ya toujours isabelle irait faire
cette réalité l'homme qui fait que nos
communautés doivent évidemment faire
appel à des institutions qui sont
québécois ans pour avoir accès un
certain nombre de services
c'est vrai pour la santé de toute
évidence parce que c'est un gros secteur
secteur important qui nous communauté
interpelle beaucoup pour des raisons
évidentes on est vraiment au champion
17,6 qu au niveau des conditions
sociales et de santé
la même chose au niveau de l'éducation
donc il ya toujours cette espèce de
gérer de croisement non entre d'un côté
la responsabilité fédérale et la
responsabilité entre guillemets du
québec qui s'exprime à travers notre
accès ou l'accès de nos communautés à
des actions québécoise donc on doit
trouver une façon de mettre un peu
d'ordre
parce que en bout de ligne au ccc la
personne le citoyen d'octobre où la
citoyenne autochtone qui qui peut qui
peut en souffrir
si on pas de clarté l'eau dans cette
relation à trois en même temps c'est pas
une relation évidente parce que dans
votre cas vous représentez quoi neuf
nations autochtones au québec
quarante trois communautés au canada
oui avec des besoins qui sont très
différents aussi d'une communauté à
l'autre d'une nation à l'autre alors
déjà au départ vous même vous devez vous
en tant d'entre vous avec les
différentes communautés les différentes
nations aussi et puis ensuite allé
négocier tous ensemble devant
gouvernement n'était en fait pas
abstraction des réalités plus gens se
garent géopolitique aussi oui oui
isabelle il référait tantôt y le les
nations qui sont partir des conventions
traité moderne c'est la réalité depuis
quarante ans maintenant
oui il ya les autres seules les nations
qui ne s'apprend qui ne sont pas
conventionné et notre réalité à nou puis
je pense que c'est devenu évident avec
le la venue d'un nouveau gouvernement
un nouvelle idéologie gouvernement qu'à
caisse depuis un an c'est notre défi à
nous c'est de faire converger les
différences vers un objectif une
destination et je pense qu'on
on ignore quand même réussit assez bien
après il ya la déclaration de l'onu qui
est vraiment pour nous une pièce
maîtresse et qui mais je pense l'odieux
est vraiment entre les mains du
gouvernement
et parce que on regarde un peu les 15
derniers dernier mot comme vous le dites
moi je suis au niveau de la relation
avec le premier ministre du québec
l'enjeu serait extrêmement inquiète
c'est une confiance qui s'était établi
me plaît c'est que il ya eu quelques
histoires à succès qui prennent la forme
de deux sous investis ici et là oui à
travers certaines communautés beaucoup
dans les centres urbains mais au niveau
de la relation politique non c'est là
qu'on accuse le plus dur attend et c'est
extrêmement extrêmement malheureux et je
pense qu'on ne nous devant nous un
gouvernement écouter les demandes au
haut niveau fédéral vient de sortir qui
confirme des objectifs précis à
atteindre pour chaque ministre du
cabinet trudeau il ya passe au québec
au niveau fédéral way et il n'y a pas
l'équivalent québec alors que ce devrait
être le cas à mon sens si le dossier où
les enjeux autochtones sont à chaque
point d'eau importants comme l'indiquent
la mine est d'amour comme l'indiquent le
premier ministe legault ben ce serait
quelque chose qui serait
tout à fait naturel en ce gouvernement
non alors que on se doit constamment
d'être vigilant en veille face tous les
ministères du gouvernement du québec qui
est malheureusement à devoir réagir
parce que c'est notre rôle c'est notre
responsabilité de garder les yeux
ouverts et de critiquer lorsque ces
malheureux allons voir sur le terrain
comment ça se passe donc avec un exemple
concret on va se tourner vers la chef
adrian jérôme je ne vous avais pas
oublier madame jérôme vous êtes dans une
communauté vous avez beaucoup de défis à
relever dans votre communauté comment se
passe votre relation avec la ministre
des affaires autochtones du québec
comment ça se déroule pour vous
concrètement sur le terrain
êtes vous satisfaite du travail qui a
été fait du gaz mois maintenant
moi je te dirai non parce que il n'y a
pas grand-chose qui a bougé dans la
sécurité des femmes
c'est le nouveau à la participation
provincial au niveau de la sécurité
publique pour nos communautés ça pas
vraiment bougé 1
si on a on a même des rapports aux
autres qui nous dit que c'est combien ça
prend aux policiers dans une communauté
on a tout
on a tout monté un scénario pour prouver
qu'on a besoin de plus de sécurité dans
nos communautés bien aussi je te dis
c'est avec lolo gouvernance on participe
beaucoup nous autres à des commissions
comme la commission des relations sur
les citoyens et nos femmes ont participé
ça a été fait par le gouvernement comme
du québec mais ça a été tabletté paie là
on vient avec le rapport vient tilloles
minus avec sa sortie madame ministre
damas à sanaa est passée comme à moi je
me sens pas respecté là dedans je me
sens pas non plus écoutés parce que j'ai
participé ma communauté à participer
beaucoup dans cette dans cette
commission
pis là c'est comme si on avait encore
parlé pour rien puis là il va voir un
autre commission qui s'en vient mais qui
demande la participation mais sait on
voit où avec toutes ces commissions là
dans nos communautés t on à pas moi
voilà je me sens pas écouté je sais
comme si j'étais rien dit ben c'est ben
beau le québec qui veut et ben il veut
il veut mettre des règlements chinon qui
il vient comme dans l'éducation le
ministère de l'éducation du québec qui
nous dit mais ça prend soit 65 cents
pour avoir ton diplôme d'études
secondaires mais là tant il s'agit de
lui demander le financement ben non ici
il nous revient d'abord il dit c'est la
compétence fédérale
mais attendez pour revenir et la
commission vient parlons-en fait bon
elle a été déposée en septembre dernier
la lâchait la ministre vous a rencontré
d'ailleurs vous à rencontrer
quoi quelques semaines après le décès
exactement la première oui c'est ça le
17 octobre il ya une âme et remy
rencontre pour laquelle vous n'avez pas
été nécessairement satisfait je pose la
question où chef picard
mettez moi non puis plusieurs des chefs
vont ils anticipaient aussi et c'est là
que qu'on peut sans doute constaté ce
que j'avançais plus tôt au gouvernement
de prouver le contraire que la question
on les questions où les enjeux qui nous
intéresse non non peut-être pas le poids
nécessaire au niveau de l'ensemble du
gouvernement
après avoir rencontré monsieur legault
en novembre 2018
quelques semaines après l'élection
provinciale où il s'est extrêmement
apprécié par les chefs d'avoir le
premier ministre en a trois heures est
ce que en raison de la teneur du rapport
vient et de la façon que qu'ont été mis
en évidence les lacunes importantes au
niveau du système
oui oui les systèmes on avait dit bon
est-ce que ça n'a pas été important que
le premier ministre soit là pour
confirmer son engagement puisqu'il y en
a parlé pendant toute la campagne
électorale il y en a parlé par la suite
un désaccord de dpd bras x on sait pas
trop 5 6 7 8 ou au niveau du québec bon
sk pas justement comme responsabilité
d'établir cette confiance
oui et pour moi c'est très clair
écoutez je port rien personnalisé mais
il ya des gestes qui ont été posés
notamment le fait qu' on est une
ministre qui est unilingue français
n'offre pas seulement français alors
qu'on sait très bien que la réalité
c'est que nos communautés s'exprime dans
les deux langues officielles anglais et
français
je touche je trouve ça tout à fait mais
sauf pour multiprimé premier ministre et
je pense qu'ils auraient eu il y aurait
dû y avoir un minimum de sensibilité par
rapport à son nom quelques jours j'ai eu
l'impression qu'elle ait pas grand monde
qui vous comprenez cette première
fouille était la question sera posée à
ceux qui s'expriment à l'un des
principal main puis je n'ai pas vraiment
pas surpris de la réponse puisque sans
doute pas très très éloignées de la
mienne est ce aussi de dresser pour les
intérêts ce père madame d'amour mais en
même temps au delà tous au c'est ça qui
me faisait bon est-ce que ce doux si
l'on est assez important pour les culés
une deuxième rencontre qui était prévu
ça devait avoir lieu avant le temps des
fêtes c'est à votre demande qu'elle a
été reportée en janvier non cette
deuxième rencontre tout à fait on a déjà
des dates imposées gouvernement du
québec et pour revenir à l'article que
auquel référé la chef jérôme un peu plus
tôt ça a été on était vraiment pris par
surprise parce que les contacts sont
sont maintenues avec le cabinet de la
ministre d'amour on avait convenu on
avait expliqué pourquoi la rencontre
devrait être reportée la ministe d'amour
ça rapporte à son premier ministre
moi j'aime rapporté 43 communauté et on
en a parlé tout à l'heure ses dix
nations ces dix façons de voir les
choses
ça doit être respectée puis on a des
structures de gouvernance qui ne sont
pas qui ne sont pas ceux du gouvernement
du québec dont ils sont aussi il faut
composer avec cette réalité dans l'eau
si on est vraiment avec la volonté de
s'engager politiquement et d'ailleurs je
me demande s'ils existent là dessus si
une réelle intention là de peut-être de
s'écarter de la dimension politique ce
qui regarde le dossier à la lumière de
ce que je lis de ce que j'entends depuis
qu'elle est parce que la ministre
d'amour est prête à agir est prête à
mettre en place la une des
recommandations entre autres sur les
femmes et les enfants de l'attirer de
l'âme
la commission vient donc elle est prête
à agir elle ne peut pas attendre cette
deuxième rencontre pour commencer déjà à
travailler entre autres avec certaines
organisations
c'est pas une bonne chose déjà de mettre
le travail de l'avant d'agir
immédiatement
mais écoutez ce jeu pour prendre le
plancher mais on a déjà une idée là deux
des limites qui seront sans doute
imposer leur jeu d'y imposer c'est
peut-être trop mots mais au niveau de la
déclaration de l'onu à la rencontre du 7
octobre - un des commentaires qui a été
exprimé par le québec à travers la
ministre d'amour c'est que
ses potes tout l'or qui doit être sur la
table donc on a déjà fixé une limite
d'un plafond par rapport à cette
question
écoutez je disais un peu plus tôt que
normalement quand on se compare on se
console mais pas dans ce cas ci parce
que je regarde un pull des avancées du
côté du gouvernement de la
colombie-britannique en quelques
semaines là je dirais même en un temps
record on a réussi à proposer un projet
de loi à l'assemblée législative à la
faire boiter dans un contexte de
gouvernement minoritaire vous de le dire
est actuellement au moment où on se
parle il ya déjà des travaux qui sont en
cours pour l'harmonisation des lois de
la colombie britannique avec les
principes de la déclaration
donc je pense que le québec l'on a
vraiment du rattrapage à faire ainsi
l'intention politiques irréelles de
l'homme alors chef jérôme
avez vous l'impression d'être mises de
côté lorsque la ministre d'amour dit oui
je vais aller travailler dans j'imagine
que si elle passe du côté de votre
communauté lac-simon elle va s'arrêter à
val d'or elle va aller rencontrer les
gens au centre d'amitié autochtone et
c'est avec les gens au centre d'amitié
autochtone qu'elle va commencer à
établir la des solutions pour venir en
aide aux femmes et aux enfants vous
auriez voulu qu'elle passe par votre
communauté en premier mais bien sûr
parce que la plupart
des personnes qui ont passé à la
commission je pense que ça vient de nos
communautés
je sais pas pourquoi mais souvent
l'assemblée nationale quand ils font des
commissions mais y viennent nous
chercher dans les communautés mais
pourquoi pour rien moi je me sens pas
écouté je me sens pas respecté ma
communauté n'est pas respectée cesser
les gens de chinois qui dénonce le plus
souvent mais non c'est on étend ses
on est assez de temps jeudi mme wallace
et c'est vraiment irrespectueux c'est
vous dieu et respectueux au long de vos
longs de des gens de ma communauté
qu'est ce qui vous donne cette
impression j'ai commandé dans leur
logique
excusez-moi ya investi des négociations
d'entre deux alors je vais vous laisser
y aller je vais je vais arrêter de vous
interrompre allez-y mais ils viennent
nous consulter vient nous chercher
mais pourquoi on est pas on n'est pas
après danser dans ses actions puis là
ils disent à servir d'abord ben les
chefs fait les grands chefs là au revoir
moi je m'envoie voir les centres
d'amitié c'est la ministre des affaires
autochtones
la ministre des affaires autochtones
ça se passe aux seychelles non parce que
nous autres
t c'est presque à 100% on est des
autochtones en dedans toute la
communauté la mme élise autochtone qui
comme ceux qui sont dans dans les
organisations ne sont pas désolé au
contraire ils trouvent intéressant
khamis viennent verront directement mais
je pense que c'est normal je pense que
c'est sûr qu'ici au d'avancement peu
importe où ils vont rejoindre contemple
c'est pas pour mettre les en réserve
avec les autochtones qui vivent sous
réserve
en parallèle loi en compétition mais
c'est peut-être c'est que le démontrent
les écarts de niveau de vie au niveau
des autochtones qui vivent sous réserve
sont hautement plus important que mon
apport à ceux qui vivent aux réserves on
est donc il faut s'y intéresser aussi et
avec respect comme le disait un chef
picard il madone gérons le sang n'a
jamais été dans sa gamme un thé dansant
bah sa compétence c'est ce qui nous dit
tout le temps où c'est plate à dire mais
c'est de la compétence fédérale
c'est plate à dire c'est la compétence
fédérale de la part d'un ministre des
affaires autochtones
- tu sais c'est un c'est regrettable de
voir danger mais gare au début vous le
disiez les choses avaient changé au
cours des décennies
il ya eu un rapprochement aussi avec la
province en fait avec le gouvernement du
québec
écoutez c'est vraiment une longue
histoire ou de l'eau de ce conte ce
qu'on a présentée comme information qui
est plus qu'importante c'est que nous le
ses mains je dire on a toujours la
responsabilité de trouver d'essayer de
trouver les bonnes conditions pour
engager temps de faire halte que la
province est l'exemple qui vient à
l'esprit est très récent celui de la loi
92 maintenant qui est fédéral et qui va
permettre finalement à nos propres
gouvernements de pouvoir se doter de
lois pour gérer d'autres la question des
soins la famille à l'enfance et qui
vient un peu peut-être
remettre en question le les failles du
système québécois en matière de
protection de la jeunesse et pour nous
bien la loi fédérale nous confirme cette
responsabilité-là cette compétence l'on
est le mieux qu'on puisse faire de bonne
foi c'est d'engager gouvernement du
québec et il semble y avoir beaucoup de
résistance du côté du québec alors que
la loi fédérale prévoit qu'on puisse
conclure des ententes des accords de
coordination de collaboration avec les
juridictions provinciales
il ya une haute notre projet de loi qui
va être reporté à l'année prochaine la
prochaine session qui touchent le
domaine des pharmacies et projet de loi
31 et qui contenaient des amendements
qui nous étaient spécifiques en fonction
des appels à la justice de l'enquêté
nationale sur les femmes et jeunes
filles autochtones assassiné disparu et
là encore on a eu un premier signal au
printemps 2010 9 après ce silence total
jusqu'au moment où le projet de loi est
sur la table de l'assemblée nationale et
et qui nous amène finalement encore une
fois dans un
dans un finalement dans une réaction
qu'ont qu'on souhaite jamais mais si la
situation l'exigé ben on va réagir et
c'est ce qu'on a fait c'est malheureux
que ça soit comme ça veut dire pour un
gouvernement qui est qui promu le
partenariat et la collaboration des
grosses pressions tout le temps mis de
côté becqueter ce que j'entends de la
ministre c'est que on va en parler de la
déclaration
on va s'asseoir puis on va en discuter
mais jusqu'à temps que ça arrive là
c'est business as usual un bon français
c'est comme ça que ça se passe c'est ce
que je comprends encore une fois la
ministre a toute latitude de démontrer
le contraire nous comme je dis comme je
viens de le dire on en rate toujours la
responsabilité de trouver les bonnes
formules pour engager les deux
gouvernements mais pas je dirais pas à
n'importe quelle condition
on est on est une partie par lui a remis
trois mais alors qu'est-ce qui a évolué
depuis un an ou es ce que vous avez vu
des des dossiers qui ont évolué pour le
mieux pour les autochtones chef jérôme à
lac simon en fait à val d'or aujourd'hui
là qu'est ce que vous avez vu de bon
dans votre communauté depuis 15 mois
depuis l'arrivée au pouvoir de la caq
chose parce que la 4k est arrivé là
c'est comme et après la fed à prendre je
pense maintenant chez nous
je vois pas dire grand chose à part
qu'elle est venue dernièrement le 16
novembre mais t on à exprimer nos
besoins exprimés non réalité un
souverain anodisé mais c'est de la
compétence fédérale
c'est de la compétence fédérale on a été
certes et on a une enveloppe maintenant
de développement économique et au niveau
du québec mais pas plus on a besoin on a
exprimé ce nouveau venu au besoin par
rapport à la sécurité par rapport à t1
au sous-financement
de la sécurité publique on a parlé aussi
qu'on était d'un inconnu
on se le cachera pas la communauté de
lac simon teillé dans la convention de
la baie james
si on était en toréant t on on n'a
jamais été signataires on n'a jamais si
la personne qui est venu nous demander à
lac simon
je viens vous voir parce qu'on va
éteinte vos droits
il ya personne n'y a personne qui nous
l'a dit puis moi je jeu les rappeler
mais tu es les autres
le gouvernement du québec c'est certain
qu'ils qui adoptera paul la déclaration
des nations unies parce qu'il ya eu il
ya eu du tort à fait à bien des
communautés pc la déclaration il dit qu'
il faut réparer cet art là est ce que le
québec est prête à réparer tout ça parce
qu'il nous a faite du temps témoin je
prends n'a jamais cédé on n'a jamais
cédé non droit on a germain céder le
territoire mais je lis rappeler de ça
pourtant du côté de la carte finalement
on l'a on a on a voté la motion qui a
été déposée au mois d'octobre dernier
donc il ya quand même une ouverture wi
fi nalement l'accepter cette déclaration
des nations unies non c'est pas
s'épanouir façon même si vous voyez la
sortie de vous voyez la sortie de madame
d'amour mais c'est tiré d'un genre de
son gouvernement
vous voyez la sortie de monsieur pierre
dufour par rapport à aller caribou t&d
c200 nos consuls tc tirer encore d'un
gendre de son gouvernement monsieur le
ministre le goût mais va falloir c'est
parti lance ce ce participé et qui se
consacra à dire oui on va respecter on
va on va travailler avec les autochtones
on va travailler avec eux mais non c'est
pas ça
c'est avec toutes les sorties qui se
passe je pense pas moins que ces
gouvernements se parlent
nous on se parle d'où les autochtones
ans par on a des assemblées des chefs
on a des assemblées de conseil très beau
en armes
on a une réunion c'est dans nos conseils
des communautés nous on se parle alors
chez mc oui car à son équipe
oui chef picard vous vous parlez alors
qu'avez-vous un plan d'action pour
retourner devant la ministre et il lui
dira écoutez nous je reviens à ce que je
faisais un peu plus tôt ça ça mérite
vraiment d'être compris on peut pas
précipiter les choses parce qu'il y a je
dois des différences quand même
importante entre nos nations
on doit composer avec deux langues
oui de travail oui son anglais français
on doit aussi respecter les différences
géopolitique
il ya des considérations avoir des
obligations du québec à l'endroit des
groupes conventionnés ne sont pas les
mêmes qu'avec les autres groupes donc il
ya tout ça comme diversité chez nous
donc nous on doit être attendre c'est
faso et pour cette raison la bombe de
port je dis tout le temps toujours
prendre conscience d'un calendrier qui
épaulent le nôtre il faut s'ajuster en
fonction de notre réalité
mais ceci dit on sait que c'est ce sera
un niveau d'intervention des niveaux
d'interventions multiples nos propres
gouvernements nos propositions seront
interpellés comme ce sera le cas
également pour des organisations qui ont
avec toute la légitimité fait leur
propre représentation oui devant autant
l'enquêté nationale sur les femmes et
jeunes filles autochtones à sinceny
disparu que devant la commission bien
c'est c'est beaucoup de chantiers on
note des jeux on a rencontré l'autre
jour la protectrice du citoyen madame
rêve rêverait ya justement puis ça a été
une excellente rencontre qui va donner
des suites
on est déjà engagée avec les juges en
chef de la cour supérieure avec les
mêmes objectifs que la question de la
jud x du judiciarisation est extrêmement
important pour nous il ya plusieurs
plusieurs considérations à avoir donc
tout ça c'est un travail en amont que
vous faites les écouter on prépare le
terrain oui c'est parce qu'on sait que
il y aura des instances qui sont
directement interpellé ou de lock du
travail que nous aurons affaire met en
parallèle la question politique est
incontournable pour nous et c'est là que
j'ai l'impression qu'on qu'on accuse
beaucoup de recul
ou peut-être je ne sais pas est ce que
le gouvernement du québec est prêt à
jouer cette partie haute de la relation
il ya des matins où je me pose des
questions je le dirai le sentez-vous
prêt bon voilà la question oui à les
isoler en fait j'y ajouterai à sa queue
il ya plein de choses qui se sont
passées dans les deux dernières
décennies on n'est plus aujourd'hui en
1998 on est plus en 2003 il ya eu
justement des rapports qui ont été
déposés après comme si on enquête
commission denquête commission il ya eu
des choses qui ont été dites aussi pour
comprendre davantage la réalité des
premières nations la réalité politique
on est davantage dans l'immédiat
honnêtement en 2019 je ne comprends pas
d'entendre la ministre d'amour dire des
choses comme ben on va avancer sans les
chefs c'est un peu ce que j'ai compris
ou que le ministre legault le premier
ministre le goût ne se présente pas le
17 octobre après des excuses pour moi ça
allait de soi je veux dire il doit se
présenter si ce sont des vraies excuses
et qu'on veut renouveler cette relation
là on doit on doit se présenter
josé promo ça fait pas de sens je suis
je suis la plus jeune nice les biches et
je me sens vraiment impatiente souvent
j'entends les chefs par les puits puis
je baisse la tête et aux quelque chose
le on veut où on veut pas moi la
question et la réponse elle est clair
dans ma tête
est ce que le premier ministre strahl en
janvier pour lui votre seconde rencontre
c'est quelque chose qui est tout à fait
souhaitable c'est quelque chose que nous
allons très certainement faire valoir
parce que c'est souhaitée de tous mais
ceci étant dit
le point sur lequel je me permets
d'insister c'est que comment comment se
fait-il qu'on peut s'amuser autant de
progrès avec des institutions qui sont
soit rattachée au port attache avec le
gouvernement du québec
on a rencontré la commission laurent il
ya de cela quelques semaines et ça a été
une excellente ses sauts ce qui se passe
sur la protection de la jeunesse doit
remettre un rapport en novembre 2010 et
ça a été une excellente rencontre qui a
permis je pense de 2,2 peut-être
démystifier certains aspects lors de la
protection de la jeunesse
lorsque sa touche nos communautés et
donc il ya des progrès à ce niveau là
pourquoi en parallèle je dire on semble
constater je pense que jeudi puis je
suppose qu'à plusieurs chefs qu'il
confirmerait qu'on semble constater
vraiment un ralentissement dans la
relation lorsque lorsqu'on parle de la
politique
est ce que c'est j'ai l'impression du
gouvernement du québec qu'on peut tous
fins en écarte un set
cet aspect là cette réalité là la
question à mon sens mériterait
certainement d'être posée alors est-ce
que avec la sortie de la ministre
d'amour parce qu'en fait elle faisait
son bilan de l'année avec notre collègue
journaliste à québec valérie gamache est
ce que vous avez eu l'impression pour
vous que c'était une façon de diviser au
divisé aussi les autochtones entre eux
entre ce qui est le politique skis et
les organisations parce que du côté des
organisations on est bien heureux de ce
que dit la ministre d'amour et du côté
politique on l'est évidemment beaucoup
moins on vous entend est-ce que ça va
être une
une façon et risquent de vous divisez à
l'intérieur des chez les autochtones
mais je poserai la question autrement
dit est-ce que madame d'amour est prête
à faire la politique c'est aussi aussi
cru que ça aussi simple qu à 100
et pour moi c'est la question qui doit
être posée jeudi c'est facile d'ouvrir
les portes de certaines organisations
des enveloppes pied pour tel ou tel
projet mais lorsqu'il s'agit de vraiment
se pencher sur des questions
fondamentales comme celle de la
déclaration par exemple c'est là que le
vrai test est posée parce que la chose
sur laquelle on n'a pas de composer ses
langages le temps on a déjà un oeil plus
avec ce gouvernement si il en reste 3 et
pour nous là où il va falloir rapidement
se mettre à la lotion veut accomplir des
progrès là avec le peu de temps qui nous
reste de vendre et la question vous la
poser un peu plus tôt est ce que nous on
est prêts je vous ramène à la commission
de laurent ce qu'on disait madame
lorrain ça fait 30 ans qu'on fait part
de nos préoccupations en matière de
protection de la jeunesse ça fait au
moins vingt d'un conte propose des
solutions mais le cottier personnes pour
écouter et je pense que le fait que la
commission laurent soit indépendante du
gouvernement
je pense que ça ça nous donne très
certainement un minimum de confort mais
il faut aussi savoir que être entendue
c'est une chose de passer à l'action
c'est une autre et pour nous c'est là
dessus qu'on reste souvent sur notre
appétit malheureusement alors si on s'en
va du côté de lac simon
si on doit passer à l'action qu'est ce
qui est prioritaire actuellement pour
vous chef jérôme on avait rencontré
madame d'amour par rapport
ah les prix avec les communautés mais
l'art est ce que c'est encore la
compétence fédérale
nous on en a mentionné plusieurs de nos
préoccupations dans la table du conseil
dans la table et on noie comment qu'on
est organisé au lac simon et c'est
chaque mardi les hommes seriné chaque
mercredi
c'est les hommes et les femmes qui se
réunissent souvent on a des plusieurs
comités qui demande d'avoir maintenant
une des priorités qu'on lançait le
logement parce que le logement là c'est
ça touche tout ça touche l'éducation ça
touche à la santé
ça touche la protection de l'enfance
mais là c'est qu'on demande ses
priorités la dame d'amour est venu si
j'ai une dizaine
c'est plate à dire mais c'est de la
compétence fédérale on a plusieurs
plusieurs dossiers que on a fait une
liste même d un des enjeux qu'on a dans
la communauté avec le québec
mais d'ici ce soir et on serait papa
j'ai l'impression que apprend pas ca
prends pas maintenant ses responsables y
apprend pas aussi ce qu'il ya une
pouvoir de yens pouvoir quand même c'est
6 min selon une plume pour voir 2 2
un pouvoir de nous aider c'est de faire
du lobbying mais non c'est l aviez pire
à as a slave un petit peu les mains a
dit pour moi je veux vous organiser
quelque chose bouton avec le
gouvernement du canada je vous vous
appuyez là dedans
non c'est pas ça oui c'est tellement
d'années était oui on se sent pas cet
appui l'appui je sens aussi comme à dire
ah bah vous les autochtones vivent et de
nos taxes non on fait vivre québec avec
nos territoires non recense dix aidé à
faire de même et qui viennent audi j'ai
jamais vu un ministre mme dur sombre
étude des fois parfois la gemme dit en
ligne que je m'ennuie de mai 2010
ministre kelly des fois parce que lui
nous aider quand même même s'il pouvait
pas faire des choses
au moins là il était là et attends
attends jo ils prennent le temps de nous
y compris prenez le temps de nous dire
ben je vais vous aider je vois vous je
vous ait ihya cesson son personnel
j'aurais aimé avoir
j'aimerais avoir cette ouverture là
cette ouverture d'esprit il nous dira
mais à toi la tpa yapo rien à faire va
cogner au fédéral m'écouter j'espère que
la ministre demeure et à l'écouté et
vous entendant votre message on doit
conclure déjà l'émission chef jérôme
alignement mersey bon mot merci beaucoup
de nous avoir parlé aujourd'hui
merci également au chef ghislain picard
chef de l'assemblée des premières
nations québec et labrador
merci d'avoir été présent un dernier mot
je vous laisse une dernière fois la
parole avant qu'on se quitte becqueter
en auto jour une opportunité si si on
accepte que des défis sont des
opportunités
c'est la façon notre façon de voir les
choses
on demande que le gouvernement du québec
agisse de la même façon et si on ne
s'est tu
cette idée là en tête je pense qu'ils
ont encore possible de faire de réaliser
plein gré dos et donc c'est une question
d'attitude une question aussi de savoir
et sponsors que j'ai commencé plus tôt à
10 ans si j'étais premier ministre
québec je serais inquiet parce que là on
est en train de vraiment long on y lit
un sentier qui est long on sort pas des
sentiers battus à l'heure actuelle et
pour moi l'odieux repose beaucoup entre
les mains de l'actuel gouvernement du
québec
mais l'opportunité est là moi je
continue à être optimiste et yachts est
certes un chef qui m'a voudrait mais je
continue à l'être parce que j'ai cette
responsabilité l'homme - et c'est comme
ça que je la comprends c'est comme ça
que je les accepte
il faut il faut que qu'on ait le même
sentiment de leur côté voilà alors le
message est passé j'espère que la
ministre d'amour va va réagir va
répliquer dommage qu'elle n'était pas là
aujourd'hui pour le faire nous le
regrettons vivement mais bon vous étiez
là vous de votre côté pour parler merci
beaucoup et merci isabelle picard
à la semaine prochaine on va changer de
sujet la semaine prochaine on
s'intéresse à l'alimentation alors
l'alimentation autochtone et évidemment
comme moyen de décolonisation je pense
que ça va être un sujet assez
passionnant avant le temps des fêtes
merci à vous à la semaine prochaine
[Musique]